>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Pause ]
>> Fenella France:
Good morning everyone.
I'm Fenella France, Chief
of the Preservation Research
and Testing Division,
and it's we appreciate
to have you here this morning for
this Tops Presentation entitled
"From Words to Diagrams
in Automated Visualization
of Historical Book
Binding Structures".
Our speaker today is
Dr. Alberto Campagnolo,
who is the CLIR/DLF/Mellon
Fellow for Data Curation
and Medieval Studies
in the Presentation Research
and Testing Division.
He's here from 2016 to 2018.
He trained as a book conservator
in Spoleto, Italy in 2001,
and has worked in [inaudible]
in various institutions,
including the Guildhall Library,
the London Metropolitan
Archives and the Vatican Library.
He studied conservation of library
materials across Foscari University
in Venice in 2006, and holds an MA
in Digital Culture and Technology
from King's College, London 2009.
He then decided to pursue
a PHD in Digital Humanities
that automated visualization of
historical bookbinding structures
from the University of the
Arts, London, then [inaudible],
completing that in 2007 to 2015.
He served on the Digital
Medieval Board since 2014,
and is the Director, and
has directed since 2015.
He is especially interested
in the digital representation
of the physicality of books and
book bindings in particular,
and we're delighted to have you
here for two years as the postdoct,
and I'm delighted to see some
of the CLIR colleagues
in this audience also.
So, I'll hand over to Alberto.
Please welcome.
[ Applause ]
>> Alberto Campagnolo:
Thank you, Fenella.
Thank you very much having me
come here for the presentation.
So, yeah, I'm here as a DF fellow in
Data Curation for Medieval Studies.
However, today, I'm not
going to present you
with post doctoral
project I'm doing here,
but I will present the
PHD research that I did.
I will try though to
put it into perspective,
because I see the two projects
as it matches one to the other,
so we'll see in the end how the
two things greatly fit together.
And, so the talk today will
develop in three main parts.
First we look into how binding
and binding structures are
traditionally presented in the web
and catalogues, then we'll look more
specifically into the project I did
for the PHD, and then as I said,
we'll try to put it together
for the end for the conclusions.
Normally when I present, I kind
of, I use the slide to try and put
into one big picture my
kind of unusual career,
because as Fenella said, I was
born as a book conservator,
and I studied conservation
in Spoloto University
and Ca' Foscari University, Venice,
but I always had a kind of interest
into [inaudible] humanities,
and then I did the Master
in this regards at Technology
at King's College, London,
and I started bringing everything
together, where with the PHD
at the Ligatus Center,
University of the Arts, London.
So, the two careers might
see like they are kind
of the opposite of the other.
One is very much analog and the
other one is by definition digital,
but I actually see them as very much
complimentary, one of the other,
and in fact, as a consequence,
the result of my experience
as a book conservator for many
years, then my research interest
in digital humanities is focusing
on the way in which books are
and can be portrayed in these
projects, books as objects.
And of all the different aspects as
the book as an object [inaudible],
book binding structures
are a prominent one,
mostly because if it weren't
for the binding structures,
we wouldn't have the object to
start, and so that's how we look
at how binding structures
are traditionally presented.
It is true that now a days,
we do find some information
about the bindings in
these type projects.
We didn't used to be
like this in the past,
but now we do have information, as
in we do have pictures of the covers
of the books; the left and right
covers, the spine and the edges.
However, what we do have is just
the images without metadata,
so we cannot do any
kind of research on it.
There are some real exceptions,
and the binding catalog
from the Folger Shakespeare Library
is one of these few exceptions,
where we do find some
information about the structure.
But for the most part, all we get
is the images without metadata,
and when we have some of these
pictures, it's literally skin deep.
This is not just for wet
projects and catalogues in mind,
but it is very much engrained
into the tradition of this picture
of books in the catalogue
for libraries and archives.
This is because, if we
look at the literature,
we see that there are two main ways
in which books are
analyzed in the literature.
One focuses more on the exterior
of the book and the binding,
and the other one focuses on the way
in which the object
is being constructed.
So the first one concentrates on
what is visible and the decoration
for the most part, and
follows an artistry approach.
On the other hand, the second
approach follows an archeological
investigation and looks at what kind
of structure and elements you have
within the book and
what materials are used.
Both approaches are useful and
important, and both can lead
to some information
about the history
of the book and their problems.
However, the problems
up to the 1970s,
the history of the binding
was basically virtually equal
to the history of the binding
in the creation, as if you look
in the literature, most
of the binding experience
will concentrate exclusively
in binding decorations.
So we have a lot of
information about different tools
that have been used, and
some of them have been traced
down to a specific
bindery of binder,
which can give us information
about the providence of the book.
And we do have online resources that
are devoted to the one decoration.
One prominent one is
the Ion Bond Databank,
and there you see here the link.
However, if all we can see and
say about books is something
about the decoration,
what about these?
These are four books.
They have no decoration
whatsoever in them.
However, they are very
different structures.
What you normally find in
catalogues is that they're described
as [inaudible] bindings, which is
true, it's what they are, I suppose.
I won't even get into the problem
of using term value of that.
However, without any
information about the structure,
we are left with this
main major category
that doesn't tell us anything
about the history of the object.
If you were to be given some
information about the structure
and how the binding works, you will
be able to identify the first one
as a French example, then
a second one as an Italian.
The third one, it's
a Spanish example,
and the fourth one is a German.
So, by looking at the structure, we
can actually get some information
about the etiology of the book,
which if we only concentrate
on the decoration, then we
will have absolutely nothing
to say about these books.
So, what would it mean to
try to describe the bindings
as material object and in a way
that's actually informative;
we understand how the object
works as we can introduce it
and understand it and study it?
First, we need to define what
objects we are talking about.
Books over the ages took many
different shapes and form.
However, the form in
which we are most familiar
with in the Western World is
the books and products format,
which can be roughly defined as
a collection of sheets folded,
fastened together at
the spine and covered.
This is actually a kind of
a, is a complex structure,
it actually is a result of a
series of different elements
and structures that's come together
to make the functioning work.
We need to remember this.
When we see an object and
we describe an object,
we need to be able to differentiate
between a pile of elements
and working with, and [inaudible]
working order, that need to be able
to define both the elements
that make up the objects,
but also the way in which
the objects come together
and function as an object.
So, we need to be able to describe
both the material components
that make up the object
and the form;
the way in which the
elements come together,
how they are related specially and
how they integrate one to the other.
So, let's have a look of how some
examples of binding description
that we can find in the literature.
We'll look into binding description
that use exclusively lateral
language, then we'll look
at the one example that uses
the very specific [inaudible]
vocabulary, and then
we look into databases.
So this first example, it's
take by, from a German article
that describes a very particular
kind of sewing structure.
It's kind of a rare structure,
which ends up; it's not very clear
in the picture, but you
basically have in the middle
of the two centers of force, we
have a knot, which is very unusual.
This sewing structure was described
by Erin Auclair [assumed
spelling] in 1978.
She found one example of this
structure in a collection,
and she understood how the
sewing structure was formed,
and described it in her article.
She only describes it by word,
and then attaches a photograph
of the sewing structure.
It has to be said that after
she described the book,
the book went into conservation,
and the structure has been changed.
So now a days, this book doesn't
have the sewing structure anymore,
so we cannot go back
to it to understand it.
A few years later in 1989, sorry, I
skipped one, Dorsey gets his hands
on the German article by Flint
and has it translated into English
and it [inaudible], so
to try and be as true
to the original German as possible.
And following the steps, comes
up with the interpretation
of the sewing structure,
and makes a drawing
of what he thinks the class said.
It was in an article.
However, he says, even
though I follow those steps,
what comes out of it doesn't
resemble actually the picture
from the articles, so it's actually
not correct, but he publishes
that anyway in order
to see what's there.
A month later, Wilfill [phonetic
spelling] reading the same
translation of the
German article comes
up with a completely
different interpretation of it,
and one he says resembles
more the sewing structure,
but actually again, is
actually not correct.
So the problem here in that the
description, the verbal description
of the binding structures tell
us what we need to look for,
so we know there are the two sewing
supports, we have the thread,
we have the knot in the
middle, but we are not able
to understand how the
four thing works together;
the form of the structure.
Just to conclude the
story, a few years later,
some examples of these particular
sewing structures came up in Italy,
and Claudia Van Vestito
[phonetic spelling] a conservator
of the National Marciana
Library in Venice was able to,
by looking at the example
that she found,
she was able to understand
how did the structure works,
and she reproduced it, and she
published an article in Italian
about it in 2012, but she also
presented us with a series
of drawing that allows us actually
to understand how the
sewing structure is made.
And this is because the drawing is
actually able to show us the form
of the object, and allows us
to understand both the material
elements and the structural data.
So, that's great; now we do
actually know how it works.
And these are still there.
They're not being substituted.
And, a second example is a
description of the sewing structure,
but it utilizes a very complex
and very well-defined
[inaudible] vocabulary.
So, even though the
sentence might read
like a natural language
sentence in English almost,
all the words that
you see on the lines,
on the screen are actually
precisely defined
in the [inaudible] vocabulary.
And when it comes to describing the
actual sewing structure and the way
in which the thread moves around
to produce the kind of structure,
the [inaudible] vocabulary is
basically composed of a series
of verbs that describe the
action that a binder would do
to actually do that kind of sewing
structure, and by doing this,
the [inaudible] vocabulary preserves
the specialty of the thread moving
around to produce the
sewing structure,
and it kind of works, which is good.
However, it's doubtful that such
as approach will actually work
for something more complex and
normally for which is true for most
of the rest of the
binding structure.
So, we have the [inaudible] of the
thread that allows us to follow step
by step the way in which the thread
moves around the sewing structure,
but not all of the structures
in material are actually
as linear as this.
So, our third example is
taken from a database.
This is a [inaudible], that
was developed by Ligatus
to describe the binding structures.
Now, a little bit of history here.
If you ever find yourself in London,
if you go to the Tate Region,
next to it is the Chelsea College
of Arts, and there at the red dot is
where Ligatus' office is.
Ligatus is one of the research
centers of the University
of the Arts, London, and it's
focused on the history of binding
and book conservation,
but with the use
of research technology and tools.
And that's where I did my PHD.
One of the first projects that
Ligatus lead was the survey
of the books in the Library of the
Mass of St. Catherine of Mt. Sinai.
The monastery is a Greek
Orthodox Monastery in Egypt.
It's from the Fourth Century.
The structure during the war, you
see is from the Sixth Century,
and the library is built on top
of the walls there
where the red square is.
It's very remote.
This is a picture I took
from the, it's basically
in the middle of the desert.
It's the, the monastery is on
the site of the burning bush.
And the library; this is the view
of the library as it was inside.
Now it's being renovated,
and it's being rebuilt.
But the library is very important,
both from the manuscript
that you find there.
Many of them are priceless, but
they're also very important,
it's also very important
for the bindings,
because most of them
are original bindings,
which is unusual and
very interesting.
So the survey proceeded
in two main phases.
The first one was the
survey of the manuscript,
and this happened using
a paper form.
So teams of conservators
were sent down to Sinai,
and in a couple grouping in Paris
that would fill in the form by hand,
and then by taking in the boxes
and the writing within the form,
and then the information would be
automatically scanned and uploaded
into a relational database.
When it came to do the survey
for the printed books collection,
Ligatus decided to
change their approach,
and they developed an XML schema,
which was based on the information
that was gathered on the paper
form by developing the XML schema,
they were able to have the
conservators input the information
directly into the database through
an electronic form, and this way,
they didn't have to scan the
paper forms anymore to upload
into a database, but also
they had improved accuracy
because the computer will
allow you to a [inaudible].
It will tell you whether the kind
of information that you are putting
into one field was valid
or not, which is not true
for paper forms, of course.
So what the XML schema
does, it allow us,
it gives us like a
description of methodology.
It tells us what to describe
and how to describe it,
and also gave us, gives
us a terminology.
What this schema does
is it follows the ways
in which a book would be
put together by binders,
so it starts from the book block,
and then it goes out to the,
to the end lifts, the
sewing structure,
whether the edges have
been treated or not,
whether there are borders added
to it, the shape that was given
to the spine, spine lining,
the indents and after the cover
and the finish and decoration.
And if people are interested,
the schema is online.
You can download it from the
website, and most importantly,
every year Ligatus
has a summer school.
I believe this year will be in Rome.
The call is not out yet.
In one of the two weeks, they take
the time to teach the students how
to describe book bindings according
to the schema and to use the schema.
So, if you're interested, do apply.
It's very good.
And I actually did the summer school
in 2008, before I started my PHD,
and that's where I started thinking
about the research
project for my PHD.
Because I was aware of the ways in
which data was gathered according
to the Ligatus schema, and I
knew that it was very accurate
and precise, and it was describing
the structures in a very good way
and active way, but I also knew
that normally when book conservators
and binding historians talk about
books and book binding structures,
they tend to use and jot down some
kind of graphic representation
of it, because it's
easy to understand.
And we see, it's actually a good
way to preserve both the elements
and the form of the object, so
what I was thinking is that,
we have all formation
within the database
that describes the
binding structures
down to a very good level.
Would it be possible
to take these files
that describe the binding structure,
and have a computer take
the information from them,
and then just form that into
drawings; the same kind of drawings
that we will use in order to
understand the structures,
and that's what I set out to do.
So, I had the XLM schema and I had
the database from St. Catherine.
They described the book
according to those schemas,
and I started writing a
series of Xcel T sheets,
basically just computer
algorithms to take the information
from the XML document and
transform that into SVGs file.
SVGs stands for scalable
vector graphics,
and these are basically just
textural XML files that when are fed
into a browser are interpreted
as drawings; the kind of drawings
that you see here on this screen.
So basically on the SVG file,
you have a series of vectors
that are prescribed in the XML,
and the computer draws the vectors
for you on the screen straight.
Oops. At this point, we have
a video that doesn't work.
I need to go on this.
Let's see how the system works.
Okay, so here is the, an example
of the FI from St. Catherine's,
and a few thousand lines of
code, you have the description
of the binding structure.
Then this is one of
the XSLTI [inaudible].
This one is specifically written
for the [inaudible] structures,
and when you apply this
algorithm to the XLM file,
in a matter of seconds,
actually fraction of seconds;
this time it was 0.4 seconds,
you end up with an SVG file,
and when you feed that SVG file;
let's go back to the presentation.
So when you feed the SVG file
into the browser or any other kind
of software that is able to
understand and interpret SVG files,
these are the kind of
drawings that you see.
Now when the conservators in
St. Catherine were inputting
within the XML database
for the electronic forms,
they also had these A3 paper forms
where they still had to input
by hand some drawing, some
information about some
of the structures, and if we
compare our automated drawing
with the drawing that a
conservator did of that book,
it's still actually quite similar.
So the system works, and but
our automated drawing was
down in a fracture of seconds,
using the same information
that was already recorded
in the database.
And the system works because
the XLM schema is able
to mirror both the material
components of the structure,
but also their form, and this is
the kind of thing that we need.
Because we are dealing with
a very specific domain,
this is variable specifics
to apply this for other kind
of material objects, you also need
to be able to have an understanding
of the rules of the composition, of
the objects and the typical shapes,
but that's not going to
match the data today.
So the system works.
We were able to produce
the drawings,
and they're very much
similar to the ones
that the conservators
would be doing.
So I was happy about that.
However, because the drawings were
automated, you can now actually,
there was some kind of added value
to these that I wasn't foreseeing
and expecting when I
started the project.
So, sometimes when I was developing
the, why is it skipping once;
when I was developing
the algorithms,
sometimes I would be faced with
drawings that made no sense,
like the one on the
top of the screen here.
At the beginning, I thought, and it
actually was, it was due to problems
with my algorithms, so
I fixed that, but then,
actually some of these problems
were actually due to the fact
that the information within
the XML files were incorrect.
They had some mistakes there.
So for example, in this case, there
was a problem with interpretation
of the ways in which the
schema wanted the conservator
to describe the end of structures
and the order of the lifts,
and you see that the automated
drawing, it's very different
to the drawing that the
conservator was trying to describe.
But within the XML file,
the data was wrong.
And by looking at the algorithm
drawing, it's very easy
to spot immediately what, that
there are some problems there.
If we were just to look at the
database, the same database,
it would be very difficult to
actually stop the problems,
because the data is
scattered throughout a series
of different fields, and sometimes
these fields are actually quite
apart one from the other, and our
human brain is actually not able
to process that kind of information
and incorporate into one big picture
to understand what's going on
there, but the computer can do that,
and presents us with a
drawing which is synchronic,
and we see all the
information there in one.
So, the fact that we have
these automated transformation,
allows us to give to take the
information and present it back
to us directly from the database,
and it presents this information,
which is being in a different
format, we see it better,
understand better what we
actually input into the XML file.
So, if that, if what we see
doesn't resemble what we wanted,
we can go back to the XML
document and correct that.
Sometimes, so yeah, we
can correct the XML file
and then obtain a drawing.
This is skipping.
Okay. And we can obtain a
drawing, which is correct,
which means that the data with
the XML has been corrected,
and we have a better
file within that.
Now, sometimes the drawings
will actually show us something
that is possible.
This is a very feasible
kind of description.
However, still is a mistake,
and this is due to the fact
that sometimes we are human beings,
and we take on the wrong box,
and that data will remain
within the XML file unchecked.
But again, if the system were
in place during the survey,
then this kind of mistake
can be corrected on the fly,
and we did try a little trial at one
of the summer schools
a few years back,
and when we were teaching the
students how to use the XML schema
and then they described
some of the structures,
then we fed that information into
the drawings, into my algorithms
to produce the drawings, and
then they had eureka moments.
It was like sometimes what they
found was consistently what they
wanted to describe.
Other times, they said,
that's not what I wanted,
and that was because sometimes
they didn't understand how the
schema worked.
Other times it was
because they made mistakes
like checking the wrong box.
By the having the image fed back to
you immediately, it's, as I said,
it's kind of the eureka moment.
That's, it's only then that you
actually understood the data you put
into the XML, and understand
that's how the whole things work.
So, it's basically that the drawings
that are being automated provided us
with visual validation
which I didn't foresee
when I started the project, but is
actually quite valid and useful.
Because, as I said, in that way,
you can go back to the XML document,
and you end with improved
accuracy within the database.
Now, another thing that came
out of the project is not all
of the bookbinding
structures are described
as well with the XML schema.
Sometimes, the drawings that
I was able to produce were not
as detailed, and as
well done as they were
for me in other structures.
And this is because not
always the schema was able
to mirror both the elements and
in the form of the structure,
but by thinking terms of SVG
drawings that may be produced
after the data's input
into the XML database.
We can go back to the
schema and improve that,
so that actually we end
up with a better XML file
that describes the object in a
better way, because we are able
to preserve the information that
we need to describe it for all
of the different structures
in a better way.
Now, as I said, Lugato's
schema goes from the book block
down to the cover, but it
doesn't really doesn't look
into one other structure that
is actually quite important,
and that's the [inaudible]
structure.
This information is actually not
related code within catalogs.
You have it both for manuscripts
and printed books with
collation formulas.
As I was working on my PHD, a
project started, led by Doug Porter,
University of Pennsylvania,
and now in collaboration
with the University of Toronto.
And what the project
wanted to do was
to be able describe the collation
structures within manuscripts
in a better way than collation
formulas and to visualize this.
And one main element of the
project of the, of the project
since its very beginning
was the generation of,
a generation of the diagrams of
the collation footage gathering,
and I collaborated with
Dalt [phonetic spelling],
starting collaborating
with Dalt on this,
and by using the same principle
that I had for, set out for my PHD,
I wrote the script that will take
information from the description
of the gathering structure, and
just hold that into serial diagrams
for each, for each gathering.
Now, these are very simple ones,
but you can get to very complex ones
that are actually quite useful
to visualize in a dramatic way.
Now, the project site is still
going on, and the data is all
on the [inaudible] this July,
and it's very interesting now
that in [inaudible] things are
very exciting, and, you know,
keep on looking to this, because
it's a very interesting project.
So, as I said, my interest,
academic interest is in the way
in which we can represent the book
as an object within
digital projects.
And bookbinding structure was
what I looked into for the PHD,
and with the collation
project with this code,
then I kind of added an
extra leaf into my interest.
Now, I'm here in the lab,
and I'm not really much
with collation formulas or
with binding structures,
but I'm still looking into
the [inaudible] of the object.
My notoriety here will mean about
the actual material will offset
within the documents that we
studied, so this can be the pass
for other people in the substrate,
the inks used for the writing,
space where you can find all
the manuscripts, pigments used,
and all of these kinds of
information can be teased
out by using a technology that is
normally thought of as a way to go
for polysyntex, but is actually,
it can actually be used also
for teasing out and categorizing
different materials that we can find
on the documents, and we are
working with Fenella in a way
to present this information to
the reader using the technology
such as the cheaper framework.
But more on these in the next
episode I suppose [laughter].
I just wanted to throw
this into the specter
because basically this allows me to
add an extra leaf into my interest,
and put them into the whole thing
is actually working together
for the notoriety of the
book and these projects.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Fenella France: So I also want
to thank the very many people
we have on line as well.
Do we have any questions
for Alberto?
What I'd like to do is, since
I don't have much voice,
I'm going to ask Alberto
to rephrase that question
so that the people online, and I
believe we have 72, 77 people online
from all around the
world, which is fantastic.
Congratulations.
And so, we'll take some
questions from the audience first,
and Alberto will rephrase
so that our online participants
can hear the question,
and then we'll take any
questions from our online people.
Questions for Alberto?
>> Is there any way to
incorporate an actual photograph
of the book in your schema.
>> Alberto Campagnolo: Uh, so is
it possible to put any photograph
of the book within the schema?
In what sense?
>> Well, you're translating the
information into a digital design.
Right?
>> Alberto Campagnolo: Yeah.
>> Is there any way to add to
that file an actual picture
of the book for the record?
>> Alberto Campagnolo: Yeah, I mean
the drawings can be input into kind
of system, so yeah, it's fine.
The algorithm that I wrote
only went from the description
to the drawings, but then those
drawings are normal files you can
put into any webpage, and so, yeah,
you can integrate it with pictures
without problems online, yeah.
Any other questions?
Yes?
>> I'm wondering how the
picture deals with very unusual
or any structures since they
rely on having [inaudible].
>> Alberto Campagnolo: So, how the
system works for unusual structures.
That all depends on the
modeling behind the XLM schema.
So if the schema was able to foresee
that kind of unusual structure
in problems, then the system works.
I'm trying to think
of some examples.
Basically, the problem is
that the schema has to be able
to mirror what's sometimes referred
to in philosophy as the logical
from of the object, which is
basically all of the different ways
in which the different
elements can come together
and be embodied into the object.
So for the [inaudible]
structure for example,
I think that works quite well,
so because the model is able
to foresee all the different
elements that can come together
for the structure, and tries to tell
you the ways which these are related
to each other, I think that
works as well also for stuff
that we didn't think it would
be possible for or even foresee
for any structures, so it
goes all back to the model.
If the model is good,
than the algorithm is able
to take information well and do it.
[ Pause ]
[ Poorly-Mic'd Question ]
>> Alberto Campagnolo: So
if the language that I use
to produce the drawings
and the artist.
So, the schema was
developed by Lugato's,
and that can be downloaded
from the website.
The rest of the technology is a
standard schematic technology,
and the XSLT so that the
algorithms that are wrote;
I should have put actually the link,
I forgot, they're all on gatehub
as well, so I can give you the
link, but those algorithms only work
with the Ligato scheme, of course.
So you need to have an XLM 5
that describes the binding
structure according to the schema.
More questions?
[ Pause ]
>> Fenella France: So, we
have one question from online,
and will the schema be
available to conservatives
and libraries and museums.
>> Alberto Campagnolo: Well, if we
get funding [laughter], as usual.
[ Pause ]
>> Can this model describe
the condition of a binding;
not just the description, of do you
have any plans to expand it to allow
for the description of damage
or material deterioration?
>> Alberto Campagnolo: So,
if the system describes also
the condition of the object.
So, the schema does;
the schema was developed
to describe both the structure
of the binding and the condition
of the books, because it was done
for the condition survey
of the other books.
My system, my drawing's only
look into the structure,
not the condition, so they go
for the ideal representation
of the object.
The principle was that we wanted
to be able to have a way to compare
and communicate the different
structures with the other examples.
So, by going into the prototypical
shapes and prototypical idea
of the object, it's
actually easier to compare
and see whether the
structure are the same or not.
So, I don't look into the condition.
Yes?
>> Can you explain one more time
why you think your algorithms works
better for visualizing
any structures other
than the [inaudible].
Did you say that?
>> Alberto Campagnolo: No, basically
the [inaudible] structures work very
well, because the schema
worked well in that sense.
It wasn't working well for
other kind of structures,
like the fastenings or other
elements within the bindings,
because I didn't have
enough information.
It doesn't work so well for
[inaudible] for example,
because the information
recall is not precise enough
or granular enough for me to be
able to actually gather information
and transform that
back into the drawings.
It has to be said that the
computer is very unforgiving,
and so are the drawings, so if you
have any problems with the data,
then the drawings would not
come out particularly well.
>> [ Poorly Mic'd Question ]
>> Alberto Campagnolo:
Can you repeat?
Yeah.
>> So, I'll break it into two parts.
>> Alberto Campagnolo: Yeah.
>> So the first part is how has
the data been carried or assessed
to identify trends or rarities?
>> Alberto Campagnolo: The data
being the, I suppose the database?
Database, it hasn't been published
yet, because of copyright issues.
So we're not; we haven't
been looking into that yet,
and the second part
of like doubling code?
>> Basic external metadata
standards being modified
for the attached schema?
>> Alberto Campagnolo: I
suppose you could if you were
to use a name space, but doubling
code is very much not good enough
to be able to do anything like that.
So you can use mets, as
opposed to actually have
within one XLM file all the
information that you want,
and using different name spaces,
you can incorporate all the
information within one XLM file.
If that answers the questions.
[ Poorly-Mic'd Question ]
>> Alberto Campagnolo:
In a way, yes.
If one is possible, the schema
gathered that kind of information,
for example for the
sewing structures,
it will ask you whether the station
that you are describing is the
current one or the previous one,
and so some information
can be gathered there,
and can be [inaudible]
into a drawing.
At that point, it will only be
the preparation of the gatherings
to [inaudible] in the sewing, so
whether it was just a punch hole
or if it was like a cut through
the spine of the gathering.
In other cases, I suppose,
if you were describe,
if you have enough
information of the object;
an idea of how the object was, and
you were to describe into details,
then the drawings can
present that you to.
So it all goes back to what
you put into your XML file,
and whether you're able to describe
something that's not there anymore.
So, that's a problem.
>> Based on your visual vocabulary
developed in your schema,
what would be the best
before and after photography
that someday be [inaudible].
Some kind of [inaudible] vocabulary,
[inaudible] end sheets,
details for it, etc.
>> Alberto Campagnolo: [Inaudible].
I don't get the question.
[ Pause ]
[ Poorly-mic'd Question ]
>> Alberto Campagnolo: Yeah, I mean.
>> Basically.
>> Alberto Campagnolo: Yeah, yeah,
we can to get the full
[inaudible] for sure.
The drawings, basically, all they
do is they describe the structure
that's there, and allows to
communicate that information there,
and understanding better, then
the SVG drawings can be imbedded
into any kind of system, and
the browser reads the SVG
and presents it to you as a drawing,
and the SVG can be
including to any kind of HML.
It depends on the system
that you are developing.
[ Poorly-mic'd Question ]
>> Alberto Campagnolo: Yes.
Yeah, I don't have an example on
the presentation, but I can show you
on the, I have my dissertation
there on the floor [laughter].
I can show you.
Anymore? Yes?
[ Poorly-mic'd Question ]
>> Alberto Campagnolo: So, how are
we going to implement the system.
So, yeah, we were looking
into funding,
because what would be
a year we would be able
to actually give the people
there, the conservators of there,
in a line form that allowed them to
describe the books that are coming
through the schema without
having to deal with the XML
and downloading the
XML and installing
on their system the electronic
form, and using the drawings that,
as I said, translate to you the
data you put into the XML directly,
allows to understand
better the data and the way
in which the schema work.
So, when we try to the
algorithms at the summer school,
it was quite eye opening
to see how the students
who thought they understood the
schema when they were taught
about it, and then they actually
saw the results, they said,
oh that's not, and
that's at that point
where they understood what they were
doing, and then went to the schema
and sort of back to the source.
Actually, the drawings
functional, function as a way
to actually train the people
to understand the schema.
So, in themselves, they're useful
in a way then you have this data you
can compare with other structures,
but as implementation, what's
really important there is
that the drawings allow you to get
to a better description of the book,
so they called there,
actually the description
on the book not just
visualization of the drawings.
[ Poorly-mic'd Question ]
>> Alberto Campagnolo: So if we are
developing a centralized database,
again, the idea is that
regardless after the schema went
on to develop what is known as
the language of binding thesaurus,
and that uses the same technology
that was developed for the schema,
and amplifies this
to cover a lot more,
and it uses schematic
graph technologists.
So, it would be ideal if we were
able to actually get funding
to allow people to
describe books and input
that into the center database using
schematic graph technologists,
and the drawings would be there to
actually help understand the schema
and then describe the books, to
actually get to a better database.
But, yeah, still down to funding.
And you know, when you present
project projects about the bindings
to the funders, you don't
gather much interest,
unfortunately [laughter].
[ Pause ]
>> Fenella France: Well,
thank you so much, Alberto.
I know there was a number of
links here, and so I think
if people are interested in
some of the web links that were
on the pamphlet, let us
know, and we can send those
out to you, some of those.
Please, I just want to remind
everyone that next Tops work
on April 25 is the preservation
week, and then on May 22,
Dr. Eric Monroe will be talking
about [inaudible] cylinders,
and how we figured out
why they are cracking.
But please join me,
and thank you, Alberto,
for a really amazing presentation.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us a loc.gov.